m
durant quatre jours disneyland paris
s'est rendu à la réunion pour recruter
plusieurs dizaines de réunionnais une
opération rendue possible grâce au
concours du cnam comité national
d'accueil et d'actions pour les
réunionnais en mobilité
pour l'occasion trois membres de la
direction du parc d'attraction ont fait
le déplacement dans notre île pour
procéder aux entretiens des candidats
alors disons paris c'est une société
avec des valeurs bien précise l'une des
ses valeurs c'est par exemple la
différence
la multi culturalité donc naturellement
dans nos candidats nous recherchons ses
valeurs et en plus d'entre eux m'ont
nous cherchons des candidats qu'ils
soient capables de donner à nos
visiteurs le service qui est attendu
voilà donc le candidat le candidat idéal
c'est quelqu'un de flexibles de haillons
le sens du service et êtes capable de
travailler en équipe dans un
environnement donc multiculturelle et
amusant ce sont 1200 candidats qui se
sont montrés intéressés par ces offres
d'emploi sous forme de contrats de
professionnalisation ou contrats à durée
déterminée autour des métiers de la
vente de l'accueil ou de la sécurité
240 candidats ont été retenus pour les
entretiens ils espèrent tous décroché
leur place pour travailler dans ce site
enchanteur
en fait j'aimerais bien avoir de
l'expérience et 10 nuls c'est magique
tout le monde envie de travailler à
disney on a envie de voir l'envers du
décor on a envie de partager sa joie
avec les visiteurs on a envie l'envi de
voir la magie de disney c'est pour ça et
j'aimerais bien travailler au contact
des gens des six nations a sévi c'est ça
aux coupes beaucoup de portes
je suis jeune c'est la jeunesse il faut
bouger rico voyager il se découvrir le
monde
moi ça me dérange pas j'ai vu l'annoncé
pour disneyland mais je suis dit
pourquoi pas suspense légende ça fait
rêver c'est un monde meilleur
j'apprécie beaucoup j'ai déjà visité
quand j'étais plus jeune moi ce qui
m'intéresse reste ray
le il en éventant fait qu'ils étaient
assez intéressante pour travailler à mon
anglais ce que j'apprécie le contact
avec les clients en général et donc
voilà une fois les candidats
sélectionnés le cnam prendra en charge
le billet d'avion ainsi qu'une aide
financière pour l'installation